Wendy in hearing what packaging means I
think it sounds great if you're
established but for a new writer is that
something they should even be worried
about thinking about striving for I
think that again the first thing a new
writer should concern themselves with is
writing a really really good script I do
think and I'm sure there are producers
also who you know come to film courage I
feel like when I hear a story so if
someone ever like a writers that I've
been working with who is also a
documentary filmmaker and he did a story
and he showed me a few clips and I was
like oh my god this is so moving this is
this is an amazing story and immediately
I could see that the characters whose
story this was based on would be a great
role to attract a leading actor so
immediately I'm thinking I'm thinking
big names now that then helps me sell it
and promote it if I like let's say call
CAA and I say I create a good compelling
long line and I say and it's a great
vehicle for a leading actor and they
might include some prototypes they go
great send that over because everybody
is usually there are exceptions but
looking for something that's going to
attract a star whether it's a female
leaning actress or a male leaning actor
and I felt that this and true stories
very often it's a really good source to
attract a leading actor so I think if I
mean the first priority is writing a
good story I think with screenwriters
some and some screenwriters so they know
they definitely think of a prototype
when they're writing it like they might
here was the writing it I see Marisa
Tomei in the role and that can help
their process
I feel anyone who gets too attached to
the outcome before you've done the
process is probably not a good way to go
and the with
the cases that say more with producers
or if you're a writer and you don't yet
have us have a script on a particular
subject but you've optioned a true story
or maybe they've written an article that
appears in a magazine and it can tell
itself because there have been stories
option or turned into movies from
newspaper articles I think boys don't
cry I mean we know it was a true story
the first time I became aware of it I
actually had read it in a magazine and I
wanted to option I tried to get the
rights in salad and I was not able to at
the time I was primarily focused on
network and it was a little too edgy for
a regular network anyway she but that
that was did come from an article as
well as they said a true story Argo was
a true story and also was an article
which I think may have been that
jumping-off point for that it capturing
the imagination of Cluny anytime if you
have something that's an article and if
it's a true story and you can it just it
you can you can sell true stories very
often without having a script yet so if
you're a screenwriter that is something
to think about if there's a true story
that you like and you might think oh gee
this is a could be a great vehicle for
you know any number of young actresses
or offers a great role for male lead in
his 40s so I think it's always wise to
think about it but not the cart before
the horse where that becomes necessary
the dominant idea i but in the case of
let's say if the writer producer has
optioned the rights to a true story then
they would go out and start trying to
package so it would be about trying to
get it in the hands of a production
company that has greater access and
leverage and ability to reach out to
agents to attach an actor director and
so on the also they can try to get to an
H
I do coaching with with those who are
not represented to help them get through
the gatekeepers and through certain
bypass certain industry protocols in
order to get their material seen there's
ways that you can pitch that can entice
someone even if you don't yet have an
agent does that answer the question
about like packaging yeah I think so
yeah I would say generally ideally you
if you can get it to a production
company they are going to be in a better
position to try to attach those key
elements and so if someone says well you
know we don't take unsolicited material
right then doing it through someone like
you who could help kind of procure that
or also saying well then what if we do
what did you say that
Oh dad like they said we don't take
unsolicited material that they the
writer producer you can say all right
well can I sign a submission release
form can you send that to me and then
they should show it to their
entertainment attorney right a lot of
writers don't like to sign them but it
is an industry standard if you're not
represented and it's and that's why you
should have an attorney take a look but
it is it is fairly standard but I do
understand why it's a catch-22 right so
yeah because if they don't do it they
might not be able to submit their
project and I know for myself sometimes
I've had to do them and there's some
depending on the language that I won't
sign and others that I will and that's
where the attorney to review yeah I
can't just go online and also just for a
bit because I'm not an entertainment
area so I'm not telling someone oh you
know dude go do this definitively they
should go see an expert in that field
unless they're themselves very
experienced at reading those kinds of
documents but generally yes have an
entertainment attorney look
you